You know the old
saying "Everything
happens for a reason"?
That reason is usually physics.
I'm Bill Nye.
You may know me as
the "Science Guy."
Yes!
I use science to solve
problems and make things.
When you think
scientifically, that
enables you to attack
virtually any problem.
I don't want everybody to
become a full-time scientist.
The fashion consequences of that
alone would be very troubling.
But we do want everybody to
have a fundamental knowledge
of science and an appreciation
of critical thinking.
[LAUGHING SINISTERLY]
This class is a
shift in perspective.
I'll show you some
ideas that I've come up
with over the last 40 years,
stuff I've never discussed
on any television show,
a way of thinking,
a way of accomplishing goals,
a way to not be fooled.
It's very easy to think
something is a reliable source
when it might not be.
Ask yourself, is
the claim specific?
Is there a simpler explanation?
And can it be
independently verified?
We've all felt fear.
And fear comes
from the amygdala.
Our brain gets hijacked--
affects your ability
to think logically.
If you like to
worry about things,
you're living at a great time.
And if you're like me,
you're very concerned
about climate change.
There are more fires.
There are more floods.
The world's warmer than ever.
But with our scientific
understanding,
we can take that fear and
turn it into excitement.
We're going to talk
about the solutions
and how design will help us
all address big problems,
turning nerd ideas
into nerd action.
And that, my friends,
is the essence
of science, the
joy of discovery.
You learn more about yourself
and your relationship
to the world around you.
We need big ideas.
And those are going to
come from you and me.
Just think what is possible
in the next few decades.
It fills me with optimism
about the future.
Let us think critically
to save the world.
I'm Bill Nye, and
this is MasterClass.